(rock music)
- Class, who can tell me some
alternative forms of energy?
- [Man] Well there's wind power
which at 4.3% is
the fifth largest
source of electricity
in the United State.
- Excellent, I'm
gonna put down wind.
- [Man] Yeah, I was
also gonna say wind,
but since Mike said
wind, I'm gonna just
say weind.
- Okay, I'll put
down wind again.
- Professor Rich, why
do we have to have class
in this janitor's closet anyway?
- Because the dean
put us on probation
because of that fucking nark.
Wait, someone's coming.
Boy, it's sure good to
not be teaching anymore.
- Yeah, it's too bad you're
just a big stupid loser now.
- [Man] Yeah, you're scum.
- I kinda wish you
were dead right now.
- Yeah, you suck so hard.
- Okay, enough,
enough, he's left..
- I just farted.
- Okay, let's go.
I'm Professor Rich,
expert in science.
These are my devoted students.
Together with the aid
of harmless drugs,
we explore science's greatest
hypothetical questions.
(techno music)
- Hey, this wasn't here before.
- The dean already
gave this class away
to Professor Leaveman
from Egyptology.
- Wish they'd Leaveman us alone.
Pretty good right?
- It's not fair Professor Rich,
you don't deserve this.
Pat does, but you don't.
- Those are kind words Jen,
but coming from you
they mean very little.
Right now we're on probation.
And we could still
redeem ourselves
but we have to keep
our noses clean.
That means no vaping.
Now,
let's get started
with a hypothetical.
What if martial arts
could be used to harness energy?
- Well I guess it
would really depend on
how much energy we're talking.
If you were to
harness what amounts
to the electricity
of a large city,
I'd estimate you probably need
about 100,000 martial artists
kicking around the clock.
- So it could work?
- Yeah.
- Wait, somebody's coming.
I was just fucking with ya.
Instead of staying up all night,
I roamed the streets and
then when the sun came up,
I had an idea.
Solar energy.
Hello Xan.
- Yes, that's right.
- Yes, I am Professor Rich.
- Nice to meet you.
- I understand you're
in expert in energy.
- My company uses thousands
of mirrors to reflect light.
- Do you mind if I
get a little closer?
- That would be great.
- Okay, great.
I have this
down on my list of questions.
Why?
- Why what?
- I just have why.
I have a theory what
if alternative energy
can be done in a human way,
like through
some kind of motion.
- You're talking about
like a human hamster wheel?
- Kind of.
A gerbil wheel.
- Most of the
issues with that are
moral or
not scientific or
technical in nature.
- This is the sun, right.
So as you describe, the
sun starts to heat up
and then it creates
energy.
Now in human form,
we're moving about, we're a
whirling dervish of motion
and ha.
This is a ninja warrior or
some kind of martial artist.
He's moving,
ha ha ha.
(techno music)
So could a karate chop
charge my iPhone?
Could a nice well placed kick
boil some water?
- If you had enough of
them, I could imagine
you could attach some kind
of power generation device.
(beeps)
- Excuse me.
Your old trusty pager.
I've gotta go.
And scene.
Okay, stop.
Stop.
5.7 kilowatts.
You've officially lit
this bulb for 10 seconds.
(cheers)
- Well, well, well.
How clever of you to return
to your old classroom.
Oh no, wait, I meant stupid.
Consider all of you
on double probation.
- But I've got more
important classes to go to.
- You should have
thought of that
before you joined
these reprobates.
- I don't own any real estate.
- Help, I'm here
against my will.
- Nice try Mrs.
Pearson, you've been
in this class for eight months.
All of you have made
an abysmal mistake
siding with this buffoon.
He could cost you your futures.
Energy from martial
arts, the nerve.
You know what, an another
thing, you people-
(crash)
- Hi, I'm here on the set
of the new Woody Allen film
Bananas Two to
meet with legendary
stunt coordinator Steven Ho.
Steven hi.
- Hi, how are ya?
- Professor Rich.
- Pleasure.
- We're trying to harness
energy from karate.
Is that possible?
- For
what purposes?
- We've attached
electrodes to our arms
in order to light up the room.
So we need to use
the most expendable
energy for karate as possible.
- So you want people to do
karate to create energy?
- Yes.
I was must wondering what moves
in karate are probably
give you the most energy.
(gasps)
- Would you like
to try the hitting?
- I would like to
try the hitting.
I am f-ed and fucked.
- Don't worry Professor Rich,
one of us will take
the blame for you.
- Hell no, we're all gonna die.
- I wish I had Tater with me.
- What's Tater, your lunch or?
- No, my dog.
- You have a dog?
Cat's are clearly
the best animal pets.
- What are you talking about?
- Because they are.
- No they're not, they suck.
- If it sucks, it's a cat.
- Cats are the cutest creatures
on the face of the planet.
- They're both cute.
- No, they're not they
can't be both cute.
(arguing)
(inspirational music)
- It works, it really works.
Class reinstated.
(techno music)
- Excellent.
- That was a mad possum.